a pesar de las grandes diferencias en el
congreso este aprobó con apoyo
bipartidista una ley que prohíbe el
arbitraje forzado para responder a las
denuncias de acoso y agresión sexual en
el lugar de trabajo una medida destinada
a poner fin a este arbitraje forzado que
a menudo se usa para proteger a los
acosadores en el trabajo de cualquier
responsabilidad pública o legales se
estima que 60 millones de trabajadores
en eeuu están sujetos a estos acuerdos
de arbitraje forzado pero la nueva ley
dará a los sobrevivientes de acoso
sexual y agresión sexual la capacidad de
demandar a sus abusadores en un tribunal
estatal tribal o federal incluso si un
sobreviviente había firmado ya un
contrato de trabajo que prohibía tales
demandas y requería que las denuncias
por malas conductas se resolvieran
mediante arbitraje cabe mencionar que la
medida tiene retroactividad y que ahora
sólo falta la firma del presidente job
aiden para que entre en vigencia